since retiring from basketball that was
in 2019 he is busier than ever as an
entrepreneur a philanthropist and the
best thing of all he says a father now
wade is out with a new photographic
memoir it's called simply dwayne
features more than 200 behind-the-scenes
images by photographer bob mattellis of
wade's life on and off the court we
talked to dwayne wade about the
challenges he overcame on his journey to
the nba and the lessons he has learned
from being a dad
number one i have to give a shout out to
you and bob i've never seen a book like
this before the pictures
when they say a picture is worth a
million words a thousand words
this is what this book does
i'm so moved by the pictures i'm so
moved by the story and i want to talk
about start with you as a little boy
growing up because you were told that
you can't make it your chances of making
it are one in a million you're not that
good but you said you never second
guessed yourself
a third
fourth to fifth
um
yeah but you believed dwayne you
believed when people were telling you
you don't have what it takes i believe
um in the midst of believing i needed i
needed people in my life to
to tell me that no you can't keep going
you know because you do it does get hard
especially when you're trying to
accomplish something that nobody around
you have accomplished
that's the hardest thing because i
couldn't look at someone in my family
and say that's what i want to do or
someone in my community and say that's
who i want to be so i had to go out and
find
you know someone else and it was michael
jordan it was chicago bulls it was
sports
is where i found my inspiration and
motivation but i thought it was
interesting that you write in the book
that you strove for perfection yeah
which i think is a great goal knowing
that you probably could never reach
perfection but yet you were striving for
it anyway why
i feel like if you shoot for the moon
like i said in a book i feel like you'll
come down with a few stars you know if i
as a basketball player if i try to shoot
to be a michael jordan if i fall short
of that i still be one of the 75
greatest players
right may not be the greatest so for me
i just always believed in uh and go for
it i had no other choice gail so i mean
it wasn't like i had options neither
uh-huh you know you didn't feel you had
options no no why
it was not presented
you know and i couldn't i couldn't see
it you know only thing i could see is
what's on tv and that didn't it never
felt attainable never felt real
what you see is what you see out your
front window and when you're sitting on
that porch that's what seems attainable
and it's the struggle it's the gains
it's the it's the drugs it's it's the
lifestyle that my mom got caught in that
my family got called in that's what i
see
yeah you talk about your mom you talk
about your dad you said they had demons
you said but you never judged them
and you never gave up on either of them
no
oh i don't i don't believe in that you
know
do i feel that their route and their
role that they took probably made my
role a little tougher
yes but that also built
me tough
at the same time and so i understand
especially as an adult like trying to go
through this world navigating through
this world without answers without the
questions you know to the test it's very
hard and so sometimes
you're going to take a step and it's
going to be the wrong direction and it
may take you a long time to get back
from that step to get back on the path
that was chosen for you and that's what
happened with my mom took a long time
but
with the family's love you know with
god's will with her own inner strengths
and everything she went through she
eventually got back on this path she
came back yeah she came back in a big
way yeah she came back but she was going
for a long time he was down in that step
for a long time yeah but you talk about
your dad you credit your dad you credit
coaches too for making you the man you
are and the player you are your dad you
said uh used to make you play with older
players
and that that that also had a big role
in how you played the game that you
played that he was tough on you you
didn't appreciate it then but you do now
yeah i do you know my father and so many
other parents in the inner city
when you have kids you know immediately
those kids
are looked at as
you know opportunities to change
the way that you're living and so my dad
had to do what he had to do he's like
hey we basketball is our way out
and so he pushed the ball in our hand he
made us play the game of basketball and
i fought it for a long time because of
that
eventually i fell in love with it it
became you know part of me but you take
it you take my life as a father i don't
have to push things on my kids yeah i
don't need help with the bills so i can
wait and i can allow them to grow you
write a lot about the players that mean
a lot to you you talk about but the
three of you lebron james
and chris and chris bosh and the three
of you will be forever tied you write a
lot about that chapter in your life yeah
those are my brothers you understand
that uh that changed the way the game is
viewed that changed the way that players
of you from a player empowerment
standpoint when all three of us made
that decision as young black men to say
you know what we're going to take our
destiny
and our future in our own hands
um but at the same time you know you it
was so much that that went in that from
like when i was going through my custody
battle like i would go to lebron
you know like you've seen me cry before
you know and they would pick me up when
i need to go play a game like these
became my brothers you know these came
these became people who helped me
navigate this life
at the same time as as winning
championships and all that but it's
bigger it was way bigger than that and
let's talk about your children because
clearly as as big as basketball is and
as great as you are in basketball you
said that does means nothing to you
compared to what you really believe is
your true calling and the most important
thing to you
being a father not just being a father
being a very good father yes
it's the it's the joy for me
like i've accomplished a lot of amazing
things
but i don't feel
i don't feel the joy that i feel when my
kids accomplish something as simple as
bringing home a test of being happy that
they got to a on a spanish test
the joy in me to see the joy in them is
it's priceless and it's it's something
that i knew my whole life just looking
at zaire when he was born when i was 20
years old i knew i would do anything for
that kid
you know he changed my perspective on
the world and so for me
winning championships
accomplishing amazing things that's
great it's amazing i worked hard for
that
but the joy that i get for being a
parent and seeing my kids you know stand
tall to see them feel supported and see
them feel love that right there
let's talk about zaya she came out as
transgender i i think a little over a
year ago
i mean and i think that that just was
eye-opening for many people to see how
the two of you would handle it
and how the difference that she's made
in your life you said she has been your
greatest teacher how so
she was my greatest teacher before
before i knew um before she came home
and said that she was transgender and it
was just a way that i was raised i was
raised like man up and once i got around
to zaya it just i couldn't i just i
couldn't something inside of me i
couldn't even like punish her
right and so she started teaching me
that it's not one way dad like i'm not
zaire dad yes you have to you actually
have to parent me you actually have to
get to know and learn was that hard for
you dwayne was it hard to make the
adjustment it wasn't hard to um because
i love her yeah right and
when you see your
you're saying something and it's not
it's not landing
as a parent you walk out a room like
that that didn't go well
and so you know my wife was very
important her care was ayah
her hand on ziya was way different than
mine and so i learned how to be
uh you know a little bit softer i
learned how to to to not come in with so
much aggression and over talking i
learned how to sit back and actually
listen
yeah he says he learned a lot from
gabrielle union but i thought growing up
guys was so interesting because he never
thought he'd be a basketball player he
used to watch doobie hauser and thought
i could do that i could be a dookie
houser and when times got tough he
believes
he he said he didn't second-guess
himself as he said but tough times can
never outrun tough people i like that do
you like that i like that a lot
sometimes can never outrun tough people
he knew it was tough and he said he
would do whatever it takes to be a
success whatever that was going to be of
course and i like when he said what i
saw was real yeah what i saw when i said
on the porch that was real yeah really
and often times kids in the inner city
that's all they know is because that's
what they're surrounded by yeah as a
miami guy we should say a word about
those pictures of uh him uh lebron james
and chris bosh uh it might be triggering
for something some people may not be
happy with those pictures big three yeah
the big three big threes they felt like
rock stars they were certainly that
we'll have more of our conversation with
dwyane wade ahead including his marriage
with actress gabrielle union wide stay
so strong and what he misses most since
retiring from basketball but first at 8
39 time to check your local
[Music]
how many weather you know can
[Music]
take this whole thing
[Music]
you know you and gabrielle union when
you talk about your wife are certainly
for a lot of people squad goals couples
goals
i would argue i would say that it's
probably one of the best decisions that
you've made in
marrying her
and she marrying you
why do you think this marriage works so
well she has talked about why do you
think it works so well uh it's a great
question um before you answer that do
you like my dress and be careful it's
gabrielle you know i love it i love it i
think it's yeah be careful it's
gabrielle union the color you love the
dress i love it i love it
the material i know the cut and it's
great it's very well priced
all of it she knows about fashion too
yes
so why do you think that it works so
well well
i think first and foremost is
just to say it's an everyday
journey
for us like
it is it we all know it's hard in
relationships yeah um but i think it's
good you're saying that no it's hard
people yeah yeah social media and
highlights and all these videos it makes
it seem like it's bliss and it's no it's
not well your life looks pretty good on
social media yeah it's highlights
but i think it's i think i love that
you're saying it's hard and it's work
it's hard it's work but ultimately
that's my best friend
and that's my partner
what we feel kind of holds in
the test of times is is friendship is
growing and evolving together you know
she she brings me up pulls me up when
i'm not ready to grow and i do the same
for her and so we kind of grow at the
same time and it's not you know we're
not leaving each other behind yeah do
you miss the game of basketball do you
miss playing no you don't no
i don't i don't believe you i
i wrote a poem in my book called game
over i know
because your life is so full you're
doing so many other things
and that you know magic johnson said the
same thing irvin said the same thing i
don't miss it because my life is so full
now i miss in the beginning but i don't
miss it now you know what i do miss
about it if there's anything i miss
i miss
standing at
in the middle of the floor with the ball
seven seconds on the clock game tied
down one
looking at the crowd there's 20 000
people biting their nails yeah standing
up like i miss the
performing uh-huh and i i miss
making a shot and seeing 20 000 people
stand up and i know they're going to go
home and they're going to be better
their relationship gonna be better like
i understand like what sports do is that
yeah i miss that but i don't miss a lot
of things the dwayne wade but in the
book you write this as you as you wrap
it up you said you left this game with
no regrets
for a game that you've loved since you
were nine
no regrets no regrets this is a game
that i fought very hard to
to play
my mom went to jail when i was nine
my dad was in and out of jail growing up
i did not pass my act test to go to
college
i got a i had a baby in college like all
these things that will stop you from
reaching your goals
and i kept fighting i kept fighting
because that was my dream and i'm a
visual person right i'm all about vision
and i've always visualized myself
on that floor always visualize myself
buying my mama this beautiful home
and so i wasn't gonna let nothing stop
me yeah what's your dream now
my kids
to
uh you know to to have opportunities in
life this this opportunity for them to
understand you know uh what it is and
what it's like to you know as an adult
and the responsibilities we do have as
uh as black people in this world and and
give them opportunities to go off and be
and do whatever they want like no one
should be able to hold you back from
that and i i want to go back to
gabrielle union for a second because
there's a great picture in the book
where she is standing up
it's you make her gay yes i love this
picture i love this picture what do you
love about this picture because i look
at that and that says look at her
expression that says ride and die yeah
ride or die what does that say to you i
mean that's that's my wife like
i remember the moment that was it was
towards the end of the game did you see
her in the stands doing that yeah yeah i
paid for those seats
[Laughter]
those seats in the stadium center
i could say
before the middle of the game if you see
her i hear her oh you hear her okay and
so the moment was i think it was like
the last two minutes of the game and i
was like hey me and brian was just
guarding each other it was the last time
we would play each other uh-huh and so
at this moment the whole you see
everybody in the crowd yeah it's not
enough because they know the moment and
my wife was like kiddies
and so that's a great moment you like
that right i love that i love it too i
love it too i mean it made me smile when
i look at it shout out to bob again for
capturing the moments in that book
cheering you on dwyane wade always thank
you so much thank you for having me on
thank you
yeah bob and tell us again the
photographer this is what i was so love
this book it's the pictures those candid
moments he said that bob of course
clearly a friend because he has
unlimited access that he started taking
pictures of the family in 2008 and
dwayne's he just wanted to have a
catalog he just wanted to have arca yeah
to document to document what he was
doing in 2019 he thought you know these
are so good maybe there's something we
can do with it and this is how the book
was born but one of my favorite things
his they have a little daughter cavia
ian gabrielle she's a pistol she has her
own little book called shady baby look
at her expression shady baby
and he said she was one of the reasons
why he decided to leave the game he said
she's the perfect exit interview for me
isn't that a nice way to put it that i
wanted to spend time money and celebrity
comes with perks but respect doesn't
come with a price tag yeah isn't that
good well done gayle great job i thought
he was i love when he talked about
marriage yes those are just the
highlights it's just like in sports you
watch the sports shows you have
highlights you see the bumps and bruises
you don't see the plays that go wrong
same thing with marriage in
relationships don't be fooled by
everybody else's highlights exactly do
you believe him does he miss basketball
i believe
when you're busy like he is you don't
miss it at all yeah i i i agree i agree